President Trump calls the US economy the
best in the world but many Americans in
the latest CBS News poll do not share
his confidence 38% of people say they
feel optimistic about the economy's
future while 35% are pessimistic 27% say
they're not sure our poll says the
number one reason for optimism is the
job market international and world
events are the main causes of the
pessimism CBS News elections and surveys
director Anthony salvato is with us
Anthony good morning so there's this
interesting contradiction here the
economic numbers are good in many ways
and yet you've got a third of people
pessimistic why well although optimism
does outweigh pessimism people's
personal finances they tell us they're
optimistic about those two what they're
looking at is the jobs market number one
we know unemployment is low that's the
top reason they give for optimism but
the other part with pessimism the stock
market right that's been on a
rollercoaster ride people say they're
more mixed about whether that's going to
get better or get worse going forward
and then they look out at the world and
I see world events and they say that
could be a reason for pessimism as well
we're in the midst of a trade war with
China President Trump says China called
and wants to make a deal what do people
think about this trade war well can you
see here on the graphic tone people
think that the Polo's the impact of that
policy on US agriculture it's more
likely to hurt than help and we also
asked them do you think it's going to
pay for any tariffs and a majority said
it'll be the American consumers there's
a little bit of Lee rhiness on that in
particular if the president should tweet
on this topic or others today how do
those tweets impact people's feelings
about how the market and the economy are
doing well we've seen them make the
markets go up and down and by a margin
of about 10 or so points people say that
when he tweets they think it decreases
confidence in the economy as opposed to
helping it and some say it has no impact
at all but you can tell that they're
definitely at least paying attention to
what he's tweeting one of the other
interesting splits here is a
contradiction where a majority of people
say the economy is good but you also
have a majority of people saying the
country is not necessarily on the right
track what explains that division maybe
the most important division to watch
going into 2020 while you're right that
people say the economy is good but
there's more people who say that the
country is on the wrong track
and the people who were in that gap who
think the countries aren't going the
wrong direction they're not saying that
they would vote to re-elect the
president now that's different from past
years
we're in past elections we've always
said it's the economy right if the
economy's good the president's a shoo-in
for re-election not so much this year
because we've got such partisanship
underpinning that even Democrats who are
doing better than they were two years
ago say that they're hesitant to reelect
the president everybody brings that
partisan lens to this when you add it
all up you look at these numbers what
does it mean for president Trump's
reelection chances in 2020 I think you
watch that gap between direction in the
country and the economy but people do a
majority does give him good marks for
handling the economy if that goes back
to being the top issue that could bode
very well for his prospects all right
Anthony lot to chew over we appreciate
it